I'm at the Computer History Museum in
Mountain View California and amongst all
the thousands of artifacts here is this
a regular everyday to pot the world's
most famous teapot it's called the Utah
teapot and you've almost certainly seen
it before even if you don't realize it
or at least a digital version of it and
the old windows pipe screensaver
occasionally instead of a ball-joint a
teapot would appear this teapot it's in
the background about 3d animated
Simpsons episode from the 90s and it's
in a couple of Pixar films it's an
in-joke amongst animators and that's
because it was the first realistic
complex object to be widely used in
computer graphics in 1974 a researcher
at the University of Utah called martin
newell needed a reference object
something simple to test the algorithms
he was designing the story goes that he
told his wife this as they were setting
down 40 newell was born in britain so t
and she suggested modeling the teapot
and it was ideal
it has concave and convex surfaces it
can cast shadows on itself which is a
problem that some algorithms might find
difficult to solve it's immediately
recognizable you can tell by eye a
50-pot looks like a teapot or if
something's gone wrong with your
renderer and you don't have to texture
to make it look good as long as it has a
plain white color and it well it looks
like a teapot but it's also not too
complicated back in the 70s computer
graphics involved a lot of working by
hand you will sketch the teapot on graph
paper and then typed in the resulting
coordinates by hand and here's what I
really like about the teapot over the 40
something years that the digital version
has existed details about it have been
lost to history it said that it was used
so much for early graphics experiments
that some people could remember all of
its data in their head and just typed it
in when they needed it kind of find a
reliable source perhaps I think we not
but it's a great story and at some point
the teapot got squished of it some
people climbed us because of old
displays with non-square pixels and some
claim it's just someone thought it
looked better that way
this is not back to the digital era
that's got urban legends around it and
whether true or not there is now a
canonical version of that teapot a
digital object that's been copied and
copied and copied into all sorts of
modern culture literally billions of
people have seen
not this teapot but a version of it that
can be described in one page of numbers
thanks very much the Computer History
Museum in Mountain View California pull
down the description for links to them
and more details about the amazing
exhibits they've got here